So another consideration we might want to think about with
decision trees but you're not going to go into a lot
of detail but I think might be worth at least
mentioning is the problem of regression. So, so far we've
only been doing classification ,where the outputs are discreet, but
what if we were trying to solve something that looked
more like x squared or two x plus 17, or
some other continuous function. In other words, a regression problem.
How would we have to adapt decision trees, to do that? Any ideas Michael?
>> So these are now continuous outputs, not just continuous inputs.
>> Right, maybe the outputs are all continuous, maybe
the outputs are discrete, maybe they're a mix of both.
>> Well it certainly seems like out
rule of using, information gain is going to run
into trouble because it's not really clear how
you measure information on these continuous values. So,
I guess you could measure error some other way. Well we're not, it's not, it's
not error right it's tryin to measure how mixed up things are? Oh so ,maybe
something like variance? Cause in a continuous
space you could talk about you know, if
there's a big spread of, in the values
that, that would be measured by the variance.
>> Oh good. So what you really have now is
a question about splitting. What's the splitting criteria? Maybe [CROSSTALK]
>> I guess there's also an
issue of, of what you do in the leaves.
>> Right. So, what might you do in the leaves?
>> I guess you could do some sort of more standard kind of fitting algorithm.
So, like, report the average or, or do some kind of a linear fit. [SOUND]
>> Is any number of things you can do. By the way ,that's worth pointing out
on the, on the output that if we do pruning like we did before, we have errors,
we did actually say when we talked about that how you
would report an output. Right? If you don't have a clear
answer where everything is labeled true or everything is labled false,
how do you pick? So something like an average would work there.
>> I don't know, I mean, it seems like it depends
on what we're trying to measure with the tree. If the tree
is, we're trying to get as many right answers as we can,
then you probably want to do like a vote in the leaves.
>> Right, which ,at least, if the only answer is true or false,
that would look more like an average I guess. Right, so
you pick, you do a vote. So we do a vote,
so we do pruning. We do have to deal with this
issue of the output. Somehow ,and something like a vote mixing.
And here, when you have a regression, then I guess average is a lot like voting.
>> Yeah, in a continuous phase.
>> Yeah. So either way we're doing a kind of voting. I like that.